こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん知っている方も多いと思いますが
11月の16日にポケモンの新作ポケットモンスター
レッツゴーピカチュウとレッツゴー ev が発売されるんですけども
[音楽]
なんとなんと私始めシャツをポケモン様からこちら
そう退場頂きましたまだ中身読んでないので読んでみようと思います
はいはずめ冊を共には特別に11月16日に発売予定のげーむお客とモンスターゲッツ
部ピカチュウ
ポケットもたりつが ev お湯チューバー
世界最速プレイしていただきたいと思います
世界最速プレイ
世界正続レールポケットモンスター3角左右副題さぁゲームリンクまでお越しください
ポケモン
というわけで
新作
はい説明していきたいとおもいますん
行ってみましたん
道
4つ中と言えたこんにちはー
してはよろしくお願いします
僕を始めます
報告してないです web リークに行ってきました
ちょっとゲームフリークの中を歓迎してみましょう
お願いしまーす
を六臂活用にもくもくされている方でも
今日はアンパンにちわ
ずっとネクターの増田さんですよろしくねしますよろしくお願いします
そう退場頂き本当にアドがいえええ基本の新作ということなんですけども
どんなゲーム
なんですね
こう誰でも楽しめるはい原画た
poster for るらいげきあつ方や今までパッケージずのポケモンって結構
伝説のポケモンはいみたいな多かったんですけど今回ピカチュウと郵便
ピカチュウとイーブイのかわいらしさをうーんちょっと前面に押しつつロドルフ
醍醐になるんですけど最後と一緒にずっと貢献していくっていう風
テーマうん
レッツどう頑張ろう
行こうと言うので一緒に冒険を積みながらおおぉ
上がっていこうっていう意味も込めて
てくん
ストークの方行ってみましょう
働いています
止めきっとする
スープ
pikachu 助けてチンする
悪いん
私かわいい
大象が踏んサクサク
他の四角いのこれが8皮下注に国家と骨が入っていて骨が入っている
大
ほどっていうになっている
って言う
3問題対応
4つがあった
加盟はカラーのみたんですよ
遺伝子を持つ者です
買おうと思っていた
無価値の魅力動作
アップ区
きっ活用してるんですよもう頭に腕とか
この次に行きづらいですけどいいですかはい ev にたそうです
今後ちろん彼女の言い分もツルッ
かわいい
これ以
モフ毛も釘が動く4個1個これも
て付け
kazz k ですね
貼ってく食べていないスーパーめちゃん
いつもドリーム
可愛くっ
不能俯瞰からこれ一体何でできてるんだろう
頃から2
[音楽]
これで行けちゃいますね
まあ音楽グラフィックした時間の朝食してですけどその中にマップを作ったり
万軍のエフェクト作った
ボタン押したりする ui たユーザインターフェイスの部分に作ったりという
人たちが御旗ている
もとなるんですよ
チェ可愛かった表情なぁ
発議いきますかはいというわけでペットモンスター
レッツゴーピカチュウレッツゴー ev 最速プレイやっていこうと思います
沿い込んでおりますはい
うわぁ
幕下へ
これは僕のいいから
でも動かせるんですかねあ動く
テクってますみなさん何とかさせて操作できるらしいです
だからもうなんか寿 s 飲みながらとかお菓子ためながらでも遊べるみたいですよ
スティック強く倒すと走れますね
はないからやってきた
[音楽]
止めた筒井
モテるはずの時ももらってトレーダーになれるんだからな
すごいキャラクターの表情がすごい豊
[音楽]
すげーめっちゃ綺麗
で逆毛の使ってすぐに応じたんだ
絶対や今のおじさん絶対かがくのちからって席のおじさんなんだなと思う
やっぱりなっ
いるんですが科学の力ってすげーよおじさんもうこのば大きな墓線ところへ行ってみ
ましょう
いたポッポに彼らはれている剱めっ
あれっ
実は分ん
うん
4を
ピカつ
もう
お客様がまたでもうピカチュウ早速捕まえるみたいです
トイ
エチレンぞ
[音楽]
う酒とやった
すごいなんか掴める感じがポケモンゴーとすごい似てますね
[音楽]
あれ
それはあっなんだか感動 no
切った
まあ
ピカツーが初めての子疑問になりました
した名前をつけてあげますたんですよかな
ヴィレ今でしょ
ベーコンがて物に変わりましたはいというわけでようやく
ベーコンちゃんと僕の旅が始まりましたよしじゃあもいいきますか草むら
[音楽]
1番道路
dj
なってくれてどうなんだろポッポ普通にいた今
まぁここらご協力顔がポッポと似てるって言われるんですよ
これぞ捕まえるのかな
かぞこれ
選んだね小さい時なければポイントなんですよ
ほい
入ってるとで甘いの俺
お世話ポケット
おうどん図鑑に入って
pop が登録されましたすごい図鑑の水泳なぁ
今食らったのが聞こえを破っ
すぐポケモンが冷めるから飛びている
どうしようかなぁ
いやーこれはどっちか前よ
うわぁ前バー
ているとっ
ぽい
うわぁ
難しい楽しげとー
なんか今までの釘ものゲームと違って野生のポケモンとの戦闘がないんですよね
戦闘がなくてすぐ捕まえる画面になります
どうした
うむどうするどうした
何か見つけると思う
大きな実を持ってきた
ハーイねん
[音楽]
勝負
それかバトルちゃどうなのかなった
して次の末に来ました
青木葉加瀬のところまで帰ります
誰にも会わずに帰ってくれます
驚きものねぇ
[音楽]
思っ
肩に乗った後
[音楽]
すげーだろ次へというと2つ子さん方になりましたーーー
を
[音楽]
まさか
バトルか
[音楽]
バトルだー
gu ev だ
ハワイイ
[音楽]
はっはっ
相手は良い部一帯だが私のバックには
材料の pop がいるんですよ
さあ
なおセンター
クロス
よろしくしましたーー
[音楽]
どうしたっ
一君
[音楽]
プレゼントを負った
その爪は手を切っているえっ
何へ
かわあ
[音楽]
名簿と遊ぼうベーコンに入っ
請け負うソフトな競ることができる
まじかーマジか
ふわぁ
を
goo
[音楽]
me
はそう言い
なんだこれなんてゲームだから
ていて a
寿都郡そんな悲しい顔しないです
表情がまじでヤバい入ってゆけでピカチュウ出せるようになったところでちょっと
コントローラを沿い今からこちらのモンスターボールプラスに変えてみようと思います
完全にモンスターボールなんですけどこれがコントローラーになるみたいです
イソクジンメイ操作しやすい
たい一つに
はいもちろん
入ってます
ボールから出すです
はポッコア
俺が付いてくる
生ちょっと
ストーリー進めていきます
さあ時は登りに行きました
感じられる待ってもう一人の日数待ってくっ
出さもう1ネタじゃ
ちょっとこれでと思います
あああああ
ちょっとです
さあっ
今バー
えっないちょっとっ
はい
やはりちょっと下手くそ分
おっしゃいすると
[音楽]
機皇帝
六車
で効き目
夫もはいというわけで最初のジムリーダーの自分の前まできました
ビスティの自分ですね
入っていきましょう
お客さんのいるやばい緊張していた
4日
一生を
ているトレーナーでないと入ることを認めない
なるほど
ピカチュウの電気タイプホップは飛行タイプなら除くさんが
よし本当にされています
[音楽]
それは釣りだに行ってきます
一生は武修
いるかなぁ
ボンゴ高校を剥いに2つと指が
てくれましたーーー
よしさあいきます
ファーしたのは
武修
まず4粒で御曲です
行って来いベーコンよこれ
ウェルはレベルいっしょがヤバイ大丈夫かなん
和泉君します
[音楽]
名工のにだけでいい
うわぁカップ
ヨハン巻
ている
早くにフェロー
呪いたくなかった
といけません
[音楽]
という時に
俺に倒せる救助にあった4桁規制どっ
うわすやすやスープー
悠吾
あと一体です
学校子だなぁ
べカーでか本当にデカイ
とりあえずに退けていきます j ベーコン作り
今や下がっている
用としては
これ鳳凰
思えていけるだった
ねこの時
[音楽]
あれパーティーができた1牛してくれるんです
遊佐いえさんって言っておけ
さあそこを突く耐えてくれ
よし避けとけっ
これで
武芸が当たれば
[音楽]
ヨシタケずに勝ちましたーーーーはいというわけでさっそくプレイしてみたんです
けれども
めっちゃ可愛かったですよかった僕たちは買った行事が本当に可愛くて
それが見えて研究所とことに今回は特に高
みんながいい
いろんな行動をしたり道用コーポラたが走ってくれなければ
ネズミって競って動いてるだけねずみ売っちゃったけどあれもあって結構研究して
ながらないうんの動きをつくって
すごい楽しかったです本当にありがとうございますがございました範囲と言うけど
ポケットモンスター
レッツゴーピカするレッツゴー ev 任天堂スイッチで発動ポケットもたシリーズに
なっております
でさらにポケモン校で捕まえたポケモンもうこっちに持ってくれるみたいなので
僕ポケモンゴー結構やってるんで捕まえと今日も使えるみたいです
というわけで発売日が11月の16日になっていてまだちょっとプレイができないん
ですけども予約が始まっていますぜひ皆さん略してくださいね
そしてなんと今後いろんなユーチューバーがプレイしたり情報を発信していくので是非
皆さんチェックしてみてください
商品の詳細は動画の概要版にあります是非チェックしてみてくださいばいばーい
可愛いなぁ
[音楽]
me
バッハ